the first thing we need to talk about
today chris
and and this is not a surprise we
expected this i didn't think anyone was
going to offer eli manning the kind of
contract that would make him leave the
giants and feel that he was going to be
the guy wire to wire in 2020 that would
take 20 million or more i didn't think
that was coming he didn't think that was
coming he's not interested in changing
teams no one's out there interested in
making him their guy for this year so he
retires and more specifically his
retirements announced yesterday press
conference friday not a surprise and and
he's doing it at a good time right right
he's tucking it into the end of the dead
week between conference championships
and pro bowl he's not going to try to to
one-up super bowl week he's getting it
done now he's getting it out there now
and uh you know he deserves the
celebration he's gonna get for a great
nfl career that ends after 16 seasons
yeah that's right nfl legend and you
know it is time for eli to retire and
i'm glad he is retiring and i say that
you know almost i say that selfishly but
only because out of respect where i just
go man eli manning's a giant that's what
he is i don't want to really see him in
another uniform just like we've talked
about with tom brady and whoever else to
me is synonymous he's obviously one of
the the great players in the the history
of the franchise and so many special
moments uh and of course some of the
like truly truly
you know up there for the most epic
moment ever in super bowl 42
defeating the undefeated new england
patriots he will go down as a legend
here in the new york area for sure for
some of those playoff moments and then
added on to that mike i mean i i don't
know how many times you met eli but
eli's a great guy and you're it's hard
to find somebody that dislikes him a
teammate that's disliked him he's funny
he's personable uh really respect
everything about eli manning the human
being and the football player
yeah when the lights are on he's more
reserved but when you get him away from
that he's he's very funny he's he's
sarcastic he's a huge seinfeld fan which
scores extra points in my book and i'll
tell you a quick eli story from my own
interactions with him a couple of years
ago at the super bowl one of my nephews
was in town for friday you know people
come in go to the game and um
we had eli scheduled for an interview
and
i i had to go to the room
between interviews i had to do something
whatever it was but i was back and i was
on time i was on time for the eli
manning interview but he was on tom
coughlin time he got there five minutes
early for the interview right so uh you
know he i got there and he was just
interacting with my nephew and my nephew
was pretending to interview him and they
were sitting there at the desk and it
was just it was just a neat moment and
you know it's something that for him
it's just two minutes out of his day
it's something my nephew's never going
to forget and that's the way he was and
the work that he did for kids with
cancer that was kind of his cause and
probably will still be his cause going
forward you know just very meaningful
very beloved in the new york area
beloved throughout the national football
league and he's given us some of the
great moments in football games that
that we will always remember the throw
to david tyree in super bowl 42. yeah
the throw to mario manningham and super
bowl 46. was better that was better that
he was marching than it deserves right
yeah exactly i mean the throw to the
throat of david tyree was more about the
escape that was amazing the the throw
and the completion was you know somewhat
luck okay i don't mean to like
disrespect anybody there but you're
right the mario manningham throw i mean
that's the greatest throw of eli
manning's career and you're right these
accomplishments these were two i mean
these were the new england patriots who
we thought were just you know unbeatable
you can't beat this group they're unreal
we've never seen anything like play like
this and he forced them to lose two
super bowls in a row because of his
clutchness and that's where he's a
legend here in the new york area just
delivering in big moments where people
are going to have great memories of that
forever and ever
yeah i agree with you completely and you
know that's going to raise the question
that that has been percolating even
before he announces his retirement
whether or not he makes it to the hall
of fame and i'm a firm believer he will
get there yeah he will get there he may
not get there on the first try
over under last hour at 3.5 tries i
think he's getting in yes because it was
two super bowl wins two super bowl mvps
coming against two great patriots teams
it's the giants right it's the big
moments that he gave us yes and
having the last name of manning does not
hurt sure it doesn't if he had a
different last name that's a factor it's
it's not the determining factor but
it's a little nudge
it's it's a little it's a little bit of
a tie breaker if it's close yes and and
the fact that he's a nice guy right if
guys like tara lones and chris carter
got held out for multiple times because
the voters regard him as them as a jerk
the eli manning's the exact opposite so
if it hurts them ipso facto being a nice
guy is going to help him when it's time
for human beings to make decisions not
robots not computers human beings are
making these decisions yeah so the
position he played how he how he
achieved at the highest levels
because his last name is manning because
it was the giants and because he's a
hell of a nice guy who was the walter
payton man of the year along with larry
fitzgerald in 2017 those are all factors
that will help him get in yeah a hundred
percent i mean you know i think there's
there's three things i look at just to
say it kind of gets them over because if
you took the regular season and just the
stats and just win loss record you go uh
you know i'm not sure i'm not sure if
eli manning cause i you know again i
don't know if there was maybe other than
one year of his career where i could
really sit there and go he was one of
the five best quarterbacks in football
all right and maybe 2011 2012 those are
the two years i could probably think of
where you can maybe throw them into that
conversation there but it's the it's
three things that i think nudge him in
no matter what
you know the two super bowls the playoff
runs they made those were magical i mean
hey beating brett favre on the road in
brett favre's last game in green bay i
mean that's almost as magical as beating
the undefeated patriots you know beating
that san francisco 49ers team in the
2011 nfc championship game where he took
a beating and just hung in there like a
soldier play after play after play that
whole playoff run and then the last
thing is his availability the the iron
man-ness of eli manning you know
the fact that he played through that
streak what was it 207 straight games
and all that i think those three things
are yeah like what you're saying nudge
him into the hall of fame to where i
think a lot of people would have been on
the fence but those three
accomplishments are so uh carries so
much weight that i do think he gets in
yeah second third try something like
that
and you know i i just sent an email to
the giants to find out what the
transaction is going to be we have to
spin this forward a little bit chris
yeah because if they put him on the
reserve retired list
it complicates the possibility of a
comeback in 2020. in the event there's a
contending team
that is undefeated in november and their
quarterback tears in acl and they give
eli manning a phone call and he wants to
come back but he's on the giants reserve
retired list it's going to be difficult
for him to come back he'd have to pass
through waivers first and it's just an
extra layer
uh and and
i don't even know if you can put a guy
on reserve retired when his contract is
expiring in march these are things we're
trying to find out but it's one of those
details that at the time the retirement
happens you don't think of it but it
resonates going forward look at rob
gronkowski he had a hard window on what
he could have come back this year right
because he's on the reserve retired list
and he can only come back for the
patriots until they release him from the
reserve retired list if you're just a
free agent you can come back whenever
you want however you want you could sign
i mean in theory in theory
and i'm not going to name names because
i don't want to jinx anybody but next
year
the
in in the conference championship round
the starting quarterback of one of the
conference champions could tear an acl
and his team wins
and if you're a free agent you can sign
with him for the super bowl if you're
not a free agent you can't so or if you
if you want to it's going to be far more
complicated so i i just it's one of
those weird little details that may shed
light
onto whether or not eli manning is is at
least keeping the door open
a little bit in the event something
screwy happens this year yeah i hear you
i'd like to know that detail too i'd be
shocked though if it was anything but
like
you know reserve retired i would i you
know i just think eli i've heard him say
it before really for the last two or
three years where you know him being a
new york giant retiring a new york giant
i do think is important to him and i
also think that this year you know the
writing on the wall just he he finally
read it all right i think he finally
realized like listen you know gosh i'm
okay but man
yeah i guess it's official i'm not a
starting quarterback i think he he saw
that probably when he went to the bench
he saw daniel jones do some things where
he probably went oh i can't do that i'm
not on that level anymore and i bet you
that made him reconsider things and does
he really want to uproot his family and
do all that stuff i find that hard to
believe too he's he's a new yorker now
that's what he is he's been sucked in
just like phil sims was phil always
thought he was a kentucky guy he might
go back to kentucky and he ended up
playing 15 years and he's as new york as
they come now and that's what happens
here in this area you become a legend
the people love you the people will love
eli manning more now than they did as a
player and that's pretty hard to do
because he was pretty beloved as a
player well and you know there's been
constant speculation about peyton
manning's next move yeah
what speculation will there be about eli
does he jump into broadcasting would he
be i think he'd be very intriguing in
that role if you get him in the right
frame of mind where he's willing to kind
of be himself i mean we've seen him in
different settings where commercials
he's disarming yeah how funny he can be
right i yeah definitely uh i i'm here
i'm with you you know whether he can
actually do that with a mic in front of
them and loosen up and be the guy that
we know you know behind closed doors or
something like that i don't know i still
think the manning family they got too
much money okay they got more money than
they know what to do with between peyton
and eli i mean if i if i if memory
serves me correct they're still the two
highest paid players in the history of
football and they're gonna know that i
got the numbers okay but i'm gonna say
they're just they're gonna find the
investors i think at some point to build
to buy a team and they're going to run
it a la like a john elway and be that
type of guy
eli manning currently is the highest
earning player of all time with 252
million right payton is at 248. now drew
brees and or tom brady will pass eli
this year if they play assuming they
play
but that's half a billion between eli
and payton now that's pre-tax
and that doesn't take into account money
they've made off the field i still don't
think they have enough between them to
be the primary owner of a team right
because you need billions not half a
billion you need multiple billions to
pull it off you need the money to buy
the team you need the cash to buy the
team you need the cash to operate the
team but it's enough where they could be
a significant minority partner with
someone else who is the primary owner
who wants nothing to do with the
publicity who wants to just be the owner
yep and let
peyton run it now i don't know that eli
wants to hang out with peyton every
single day of his life i think he
probably got enough of that growing up
right but uh you know if that's what eli
is interested in and he wants to get
involved and maybe eli's a silent
partner and it's just peyton who runs
the show but i could see something like
that happening because between the two
of them they got plenty of cash chris
yeah they do they got plenty of cash
they had great careers they deserve it
they got personnel i think they would be
very good at running a football team i
know there's no doubt about that uh and
and i'm with you i think that's where
they end up instead of maybe the
broadcast booth when it's all said and
done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports